well in the u.s
democrats in the house of
representatives have passed legislation
aimed at restoring voting rights which
have been altered by the supreme court
but it now faces an uphill battle in the
senate where it needs republican support
to pass
activists are now planning marches in
support of voting rights in several u.s
cities on saturday which will be the
58th anniversary of martin luther king's
historic march on washington and martin
luther king's son martin luther king the
third joins us now from atlanta and he
will be leading those marches thank you
so much for talking to us um why do you
think it's important that you have these
marches
well um actually at the beginning of the
year
everyone talked about the election of
last year and how successful it was how
many people voted around the country but
all of a sudden
at some point
uh 18 now almost 20 states have imposed
restrictive voting rights making it very
difficult for blacks and browns and
students and seniors to vote
and most of these are republican-led
states
these restrictive laws
are under a lie that president
trump said he won
but yet everybody knows that's not the
case why are we restricting people's
rights to vote we should be expanding
the right to vote as you said the
congress just passed the john lewis
voter registration restoration act which
gives
uh federal oversight now the senate must
do the same that's what we're going to
be demanding on saturday as we do these
marches all over our country expansion
of voter rights not reducing the right
to vote it's so stalled in the senate
hasn't it i mean have you had
conversations with the senators and
congress people who've restricted
protections to that act and what are
they saying to you what are their
concerns
well the initial concern on the side uh
was on the republican side was well what
about the id provisions and that's what
they claim they're doing well if there
was no fraud why are we changing the
process if there was nothing wrong with
the elections at all last year why would
you need to create a process that makes
it cycles the right to vote that is
really
unconscionable and therefore the people
must put pressure on the policymakers
and that's what we're doing by our
demonstrations we're going to be calling
our senators we're going to be
registering over 2 million people
between now and the midterm elections
we're going to be doing all that we can
to make sure that the john lewis bill is
passed so that there's some federal
oversight of what is being done in these
states that are making it hard for
people to vote what do what do you make
comments um what do you make of excuse
me or say to comments like mike pence
right he said that restoring the voting
rights will quote increase opportunities
for election fraud trample the first
amendment further erode confidence in
our elections and forever dilute the
votes of legally qualified qualified
eligible voters i mean what do you say
to a statement like that
well first of all that is just a
political statement
for winning a position it is not a fact
there's been no fraud so i don't even
know what he's talking about i don't
think he knows what he's talking about
other than he's trying to foster a
position the fact of the matter is
everyone should have the right to vote
from an incumbent standpoint you don't
need to reduce polling places you don't
need to reduce the amount of places
where people can drop ballots off you
don't need to do those kind of things
that are being done that are
specifically targeting the black and
brown community this is all about
reducing the ability of people to vote
it is not about expanding we should be
expanding we talk about democracy all
over the world yet we're suppressing
democracy at home that to me is
hypocritical
now you challenge those um who
wondered if they would march with dr
king you're asking them are you marching
now um do you think that there is as
much at stake today as there was in 1963
there is certainly a
uh as much at stake in relationship to
what direction this country is going to
go in
is it going to move forward or are we
going to try to move backwards and we
saw what backwards was under the last
four years
when president trump was president he
was dividing us he was dividing the
world in fact and so the fact of the
matter is for the president
president biden and vice president
harris to get an agenda moving forward
that brings
jobs that creates opportunity that even
talks about the infrastructure bill then
there has to be
leadership there to assist them and that
leadership will not be able to be
elected if you're reducing the right of
people to vote as opposed to expanding
uh people's rights to vote
okay martin luther king the third thank
you so much for talking to us